hi Mike
how are you how are you great great tell
us where you are today so I am back now
and we flew home to Baltimore and in the
spirit of the holidays and and my
commitment to promote water safety
my son Dacian in prague representing a
twenty thousand to the Boys and Girls
Club of Berkshire County to expand the I
am programs at the clubs here so you
know for me I've been working with the
Boys and Girls Club of Harford County
fashions early 2000 maybe like 2001 so
for me it's always good to come back
here but also to be home through how
important are the Ravens to you
I made a few last week that was a tough
one I thought we had it when it was 2320
and then I mean Tom's just so tough
Tom's a great quarterback those guys
always seem to get it done and I mean
obvious in our our backs are against the
wall and we gotta went out basically to
get to the playoffs did you ever play
football no I don't wait so you have to
be coordinated to swim that coordination
doesn't translate to other sports
yeah but I'm submerged in water and if I
do I sometimes feel like I'm gonna fall
or I mean I just don't feel completely
comfortable on land so it's I just saw
where you tweeted out a picture of Craig
Sager when did you meet Craig about 10
years and and you know it's it's I was
talking about this earlier I've lost
three people that I've been able to get
to know last three days and with on
thick and Craig zadan it's you know it
truly is life is so crazy
and and you know you never would know
it's gonna happen tomorrow and and you
know for us losing to people like that
in this world you know especially Craig
in the in the sports world there's a
huge loss and and you know how much
passion he showed him the sidelines and
obviously none of us are ever gonna
forget his his amazing jackets he had on
every day for just somebody that was
that was so so big in sports and will
terribly be missed but when you look at
sports growing up what's the sports
memory you have of your favorite team
thank you
did anybody break your heart make you
cry when you're a little with sports
teams I mean you say break your heart
and then I guess I guess for me I watch
Jordan growing up you know as a child
just watching him every day
you know go out there and get the job
done no matter if he was sick or not and
I thought that was something there's you
know for me was inspiration will watch
the kid I also have a bad Sports memory
from I was getting autographs memorials
and a bunch of them snubbed me I was
kind of bummed about that how old object
now I must have been seven years old I
mean there's one picture in particular
I'll never forget I know exactly his
name but I probably won't say he played
for the Orioles in the late 90s and I
wanted his autograph so bad Mitch loved
me and that that stuck with me my whole
life
mike mussina no no I got it okay now you
got us guessing here I don't even know
you remember the name Bob Milwaukee yeah
Bob wait why would he say he didn't do
enough to snub you Cena was what I had
we one shot that I just saw I was going
through some stuff the other day in
storage and I ran through like an old
baseball where I had I had like Massino
coils Ben McDonald who else is on there
Roberto Alomar David segui some of the
old Orioles from back in bears pretty
pretty cool to go down memory lane
yeah you
I remember Ben McDonald I think he came
up when he was 19 and he was just
bringing it and yeah yeah at LSU I think
and he just never lived up to when
everybody thought he was going to be
yeah it was well it's I mean baseball is
also it was so fun for me watching
obviously watching Cal and Washington
break the the single game record there's
a continuous record streak that was that
was insane I remember sitting at that
game that was third base I'm not a
memory it would be he's Michael Phelps
he's got a whole lot of gold medals he's
got 28 medals in all joining a Stan
Patrick show
have you ever loaned out one of your
medals to a friend not a shot no way
haha really I was really uneven on I
mean they're they're never really out in
public I mean I I have them hidden away
and and I guess they've been out once
and and there was first photo shoot and
I haven't haven't taken him out
since I mean I never travel with any of
them I think for me it's you know for me
obviously it's a huge it's a huge honor
to be able to have the opportunity to
represent your country at the Olympic
and get a chance to win a medal but it's
it's it's something for me that it's not
my whole life and it doesn't define
exactly who I am so I I tried to you
know for me once I accomplished a goal I
try to move forward and I'm not
downplaying my comments by any means but
I have I have some some more super lofty
goals that I have ahead of me and and
you know it'll be a huge challenge but
we're gonna try and get there what if
boomer when he gets to be a certain age
and show and tell and you go to show and
tell and he says dad will you bring well
what if you just say how about I bring a
bronze instead of a gold like would you
do show-and-tell for your son I mean I
would go with ya okay so as long as you
had I'd go with them and bring him but
you're not letting boomer take it
himself
I mean they're never out of my eyes no
they're never out of my range of sight
if you could pick a sport for
your son to play what sport would you
pick I say it's still tough from number
one he's gonna be water safe that's
let's check that box okay but I mean I
always thought it would be so cool like
you know like Sunday have the Masters
had like you know Boomer Phelps leads
the Masters by three strokes I think
that would be so cool
you know I'm em but I mean the biggest
thing is you know for me in the kid my
mom I was always so supportive with
everything that I did and you know for
me if I wanted to stop swimming then she
was going to support it but she just
wanted me to think about everything you
know and I was able to really just
follow my heart and and find a passion
that I you know in a sport that I had
some talent so you know as long as he as
long as he does that and and you know he
just does what he loves I think that's
really the only thing that matters most
did it ever factor into your decision
whatever your decision is if it's a
final decision of still competing and
your son is able to watch you compete
because there are athletes who have
regretted you know Jeff Gordon talked
about he wanted his kids to be able to
see him drive Tom Brady with his kids
being able to see him play any part of
that factor in with what your future is
[Music]
there's a basketball player whose son
watched him play this saw her it's done
watch the Olympics this summer and he
was like daddy how come we weren't there
this time so I think he is gonna go back
and play at the games for that reason
and and you know for me I just I'm to
the point honestly like you know coming
into the last my my last wall of my
individual race the hundreds lot I've
never had a thought like I had you know
I had it thought coming in where I said
to myself is this gonna end perfectly or
is it gonna end how it's supposed to and
and you know I knew you know once I had
that thought that that that was it you
know this this was the last time that
I'll ever some competitively and you
know for me I'm looking forward to
having the opportunity to
to be able to share the experience with
them you know being able to show them
photos that Nicole and I both add from
from the Olympics also being able to
share videos with him where he's you
know front and center all over the news
and you know being able to share the
journey that we had I think that's
something that is going to be really
really fun for me and also I'm not
really past you know 2012 in 2016 I'm
really fully comprehended but that
what's happened over the last eight
years something I just finally got past
2008 and was able to realize what really
happened there and I think you know by
the time boomers old enough hopefully
I'll be able to just share my whole
career with him was LeBron the
basketball player who realized that
maybe you should go back and play in the
Olympics so his kids can see him okay
okay now we have an Olympic bed here
with my guys here Paulie do you want to
explain the Olympic bed that yeah mom
Michael and the 2012 Olympics after he
retired I said he wouldn't race again we
talked on the show I thought he'd be
back again yes I'm willing to guarantee
that Michael race is at least one race
in the following Olympics in I would put
up this 2020 Michael if you don't race
in the next Olympics I will dress as you
for the show the day after the Olympics
says you your work gear which believe me
Mike I'm a shape whenever you wear I
wear big guy and but the thing is if you
race it'll work
I got three and a half years to get in
shape but if you race in the next
Olympics you have to come here and do my
job for the day dressing what I wear
your dance producer to be the co-host of
the show is that really a wheel is that
a win for Michael though Paulie I mean
he's got to suffer a little bit a day
with us means a beer that's okay so you
have to shave your Chad
you got a wax your chest and you have to
wear the speedo right you have to do
that yeah okay oh okay yeah but we like
the speedo better Mike oh yeah I mean
I'll get them a very colorful brief yeah
yeah I like that all right good maybe
maybe we should probably we should have
somebody like videotape them shaving
down for the race and and get some cap
and goggles there and we'll get him a
nice little brief it'll be off to him
now I remember when Dara Torres told me
there were shaving parties with the swim
team can you confirm or another guy Dara
said that there was uh like Lenny what
was saying Craig crazy yeah like they
were involved in shaving parties there
and I didn't know well you're you know
you're you've got a child now you of
course would never be involved in
something like that how dare me say that
congratulations with everything the
Michael Phelps foundation everything
that you're doing as well in the
offseason and I I'm gonna guess I'll see
you at the 2020 games I won't see you in
the pool but I think I'll see you at the
games is that a fair assessment
I'm sure I'll see you before then but I
hope to see you at the games and maybe
we'll be commentating doing some stuff
together I like that I like that Michael
thanks for joining us thank then the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience
[Music]